[Musique]
il est 18h et une famille d'un immeuble
résidentiel de longueuil surtout bonne
une scène qui aurait été tout à fait
normal il ya quelques semaines
mais voilà quatre personnes n'avaient
pas cette adresse il s'agit donc d'un
rassemblement illégal depuis le 12 mars
les policiers de longueuil ont remis
près de 100 constats d'infraction pour
rassemblements illégaux et les amendes
sont salées
plus de 1500 dollars avec les frais
d'administration en fait on va toujours
favorisé l'avertissement si jamais se
faisait là il pourrait émettre un
constat mais le bus n'est pas d'émettre
un constat c'est plus que les gens sont
conformes
on veut on peut pas donner des gens ont
pas nécessairement les moyens de les
taxer les connaître le service de police
de l'agglomération de longueuil reçoit
entre 60 et 100 signalement par jour en
lien avec la cuvée 2009
prochaine appelle un voisin a remarqué
un regroupement illégales de jeunes dans
une cour arrière de boucherville
bonjour ça va bien on a eu un appel
comme quoi il y avait un attroupement de
jeunes dans la cour arrière de mon fils
est aujourd'hui géré ça comment les
codes délation jusqu'à maintenant on va
les traiter de la même façon contre
était par exemple une plainte de bruit
ce qu'on avait demandeur anonyme on va
le traiter de la même façon est-ce que
vous l'encouragez cela cette délation je
veux suivre les normes gouvernementales
en fait acquis si le gouvernement
encourage cette délation l'oeuvre dire
aux gens encourager la cie le quotidien
des policiers aujourd'hui rythmée par
les appels de délation les journées sont
plus calmes pour le mois d'avril
on dénombre 35 % moins de crimes qu'à la
même période l'an dernier dans
l'agglomération de longueuil et ce soir
les rues sont désertes
[Musique]
dernier rappel la soirée encore un code
rassemblement illégal il fait bon
accueil sur le balcon qui vous avez fait
accompagner de thau personnes la police
notre réalité du quotidien
personne répond à l'intérieur pour une
fois vide personne en danger
c'est souvent le voisin qui appelle donc
on sait pas jamais vers quoi qu'on
s'enligne enfin que oui je répare
d'abord la maladie d gravement malade
même de donner à ma famille à mon
collègue
t'es vraiment un ennemi et simon couture
radio canada
longueuil